I was 15 feet from this guy but I was
safely in in a Land Rover right if I had
not been I would have been a little
stressed out right my adrenal cortex
would have been squirting out cortisol
the stress hormone right as I saw this
guy this is this is an adaptive response
we undergo some sort of acute stressor
our our adrenal glands go into action
they squirt cortisol we get in a
physiological state - that prepares us
for the sorts of things that we're
likely to have to do to adapt to the
stressor okay one of the truly
remarkable things about reading a story
is that and again when you're engaged
when you're engaged with a story you get
a major activation of your HPA access
your hypothalamus pituitary adrenal axis
this is the classic stress response it's
the the system that regulates stress but
it's also essential in the control of
the immune system mood and sexuality and
energy right now and I think that this
is this is the foundation the
physiological foundation of that feeling
when you're engaged in a story and
you're really nervous I mean reading
flight behavior I'm just so anxious
about what's gonna happen to della robia
again you know because what new
humiliation of being poor in America is
she gonna have to endure right and and
it's that feeling of needing to turn the
page this is this activation of the HPA
access okay it's cool is it useful
instrumentally and I have to give props
out to my Stanford colleague Robert
Sapolsky many of you are probably
familiar but he's an incredible
incredible public speaker and and a just
a huge intellect it was has been a good
mentor to me why do we care about
cortisol other than it's kind of cool
that you get this physiological response
to reading a story it turns out that
stress opens people's minds to behavior
change the right kind of stress
opens people's minds to behavior change
University College London psychologist
neuroscientist telly Shaw wrote is most
famous she has a fairly recent book on
changing people's minds and she's quite
famous for her her technical work on
what's called a positivity bias okay so
that your you're faced with with
information that comes at you from the
world
you have priors prior beliefs about what
the world is like and when you get
information that's good news relative to
your desires you take that you say good
my hypothesis is supported and when you
get bad news you kind of ignore it you
don't pay as much attention to it which
seems a little paradoxical it seems like
for a survival algorithm you'd want to
learn more from bad news that's the way
I think about these things but it turns
out that isn't the way a lot of people
go about doing it until you put them
under stress when you put people under
stress when you give them some sort of
like one of these psychologists sort of
like funny things that you do you tell
them that they're gonna have to give a
public lecture after they do your test
or something like that it turns out you
open people's minds to both good news
and bad news and they behave like proper
Bayesian they update their priors in a
rational kind of way isn't that cool
and that means that they've had their
HPA access activated it means that
they're they're got that cortisol
response and that's exactly what good
fiction does to you is it possible that
there's a physiological foundation for
good fiction changing people's valence
bias right there their willingness to
accept good and bad news it's a
hypothesis
[Music]